[Music]
oh my God
on this Wednesday night hurricane Adalia
Roars ashore oh pieces are flying off
the widespread destruction and why the
storm intensified so quickly before it
hit Florida
FX rules violated the blistering new
report blasting Ontario's government
over the controversial Greenbelt Land
swap fresh concerns about the Senate
minority leader in the U.S
all right I'm sorry you all we're gonna
need a minute Mitch McConnell appears to
freeze again while taking questions from
reporters and major buzz kill a warning
from police in one Canadian city about 5
million bees
global national with Donna freezing
this is the fierce strength of hurricane
Adalia pounding Florida's West Coast as
it roared ashore today the eye of that
storm so powerful it kicked up a storm
surge and brought winds not seen in a
lifetime officials say a thousand
Bridges need to be inspected now before
they're considered safe and the Damage
extends far beyond where the hurricane
made landfall though it's now been
downgraded to a tropical storm good
evening and thanks for joining us those
in the Hurricane's path were warned to
get out not everyone did and there are
reports some had to swim to safety
Jackson prosco has our top story tonight
this part of Florida hasn't seen a storm
like this in over a century
[Music]
hurricane Adalia brought ferocious wind
and the incredible rain to Florida's Big
Bend oh my God it was the storm surge
that proved most dangerous everything
under the back of your house is
completely underwater
record high levels of water nearly five
meters deep were pushed on Shore it
doesn't look good uh our all of our
commercial buildings downtown are
underwater uh a huge percentage of our
homes have been inundated with water
um you can see I'm standing in the
middle of State Road 24 right now and
it's completely underwater Coastal
communities were inundated roads became
Rivers those who ignored warnings to
leave needed to be rescued we got high
tide coming and the water didn't go out
ahead of landfall adalia's Rapid
intensification is what worried
officials the most a storm for the
agents that grew rapidly in the ultra
warm Waters of the Gulf of Mexico which
is going to be a big big deal and it's
going to be very very dangerous
and there we go with our uh with our
power here hundreds of flights were
canceled across the region as airports
shuttered though major cities like Tampa
were spared the worst of it flooding was
still a problem
parts of Fort Myers still rebuilding
from Hurricane Ian were submerged again
in Tampa the Waterfront went under the
flooding is unbelievable Bayshore
Boulevard is completely underwater
Italia quickly barreled across Florida
and into Georgia where it brought more
high wind and the risk of Inland
flooding it's a dangerous storm people
need to prepare they need to be ready
when it's coming through it will take
days to assess the damage some residents
could be in the dark even longer as the
year's first major storm delivered a
warning that hurricane season is
reaching its peak Jackson frostco Global
News
hurricanes are named by the World
Meteorological organization and the
names get reused unless they are Monster
storms Adalia begins with the letter I
and more storms that start with an eye
have been retired than any other letter
of the alphabet because they were deadly
or destructive 14 names have been
crossed off that list about 15 percent
hurricane Ian is the most recent that
category four storm killed more than 150
people in Florida last year and caused
155 billion dollars worth of damage a
record in that state there is an
explanation for this odd group timing
the intensity of the Atlantic hurricane
season builds at the end of August and
Peaks around the second week of
September to help put this latest
hurricane into context Global News
meteorologist Anthony Farnell is with me
Anthony Adalia intensified with
frightening speed as it approached
Florida why did that happen is it going
to become more common
well it certainly has been more common
Donna over the course of the last few
years at least these storms intensifying
quickly it was well forecasted by the
National Hurricane Center but still that
doesn't make it any less scary and you
see our satellite imagery here showing
that pinpoint eye right before landfall
thankfully it was a rather small compact
storm so the damage was less widespread
than some of the other big ones but look
at this since 2017 all of these major
hurricanes have reached their strongest
Point within about a hundred kilometers
of land so that is a troubling sign that
we're seeing in the Gulf of Mexico
partially to blame the very warm water
now this is deviations from normal 30 to
32 degrees Celsius water typically you
need about 26 degrees Celsius to get a
hurricane to form and it's not just the
Gulf of Mexico we've got warm water
because of El Nino in the Pacific much
of the Atlantic is above seasonal and
that is a troubling sign for the next
few weeks as hurricane season really
ramps up Donna it is troubling and
Anthony We Fear winds from a hurricane
of course but the storm surge is a real
threat too especially in this case
especially in this case yeah it's really
the orientation of the coastline the
fact that it's rather shallow shelf
water here in this Big Bend area of
Florida but also when you have these
major hurricanes intensifying right up
until landfall the winds bring a lot of
water into places that shouldn't be that
was a dahlia I do want to quickly
mention that this big eye you see here
that's another hurricane it's Category 2
strength Franklin originally a category
four just a couple of days ago big waves
up and down the Eastern Seaboard but
also it's having an effect bringing some
tropical moisture even into Atlantic
Canada where rainfall warnings are in
place anywhere from 50 to 100
millimeters falling in an area that has
had already a record wet summer so there
is a flood threat indirectly from
Franklin for Atlantic Canada
Newfoundland also seeing rain through
tomorrow Donna okay Global News
meteorologist Anthony Farnell thank you
the government of Ontario and Premier
Doug Ford are being slammed yet again
for the controversial plan to remove
Land from the protected green belt
around Toronto so that developers can
build homes on it Ontario's Integrity
commissioner calls the land swap a
rushed and flawed process marred by a
lack of oversight and that he says led
to the private interests of certain
developers being furthered improperly he
recommends the housing Minister be
reprimanded Colin Demello is following
this from Queens Park in Toronto calling
the Integrity commissioner didn't mince
his words today how serious is this
well the Ford government has already
been consumed by controversy for the
past few weeks Donna but this only added
more fuel to the fire the Integrity
commissioner found that Ontario's
housing Minister Steve Clark was
primarily to blame here it was his
responsibility to carry out the removal
of the Greenbelt lands but the Integrity
commissioner found that Clark
deliberately stuck his head in the sand
because he knew this was going to be a
politically sensitive file instead he
says he handed over the responsibility
to his chief of staff who rushed through
the process and created a chaotic
process as a result there are growing
calls for Steve Clark to either resign
or to be fired but the premier today
issued a statement saying he stands by
the housing minister they will fix the
process but he says the housing minister
is still the best person equipped to
carry out the province's goal of
building 1.5 million homes over this
coming decade and so what happens now
Colin will there be any consequences
oh that is yet to be seen this is going
to be growing politically anyway for the
government the question is what did the
premier know and when it was he who
kicked off The process by instructing
the housing minister to remove lands
from the Green Belt it was the premier
who ultimately approved the removals of
those specific pieces of land the
questions of whether the premier knew
exactly who was benefiting from this
deal will become important in the days
ahead the premier is set to take
questions tomorrow in his home riding in
Etobicoke just a little bit West of
Queen's Park okay Colin Demello in
Toronto thanks
the Canadian Armed Forces says it's
dropping its duty to report policy after
a recommendation from retired Supreme
Court Justice Louise Arbor in her report
on the military's handling of sexual
misconduct the duty to report policy
made it mandatory for members to report
all instances of misconduct including
sexual misconduct or racism whether they
were directly affected by it or not
Arbor says the unintended consequence is
that in many cases it caused survivors
additional harm by taking away their
agency and control over the reporting
process the aim is to allow military
members to report issues of misconduct
on their own terms just like in the
civilian justice system the policy is
expected to be removed in the winter
Canada's population hit a milestone this
year reaching 40 million and now a
report has found the official number of
non-permanent residents in Canada could
be vastly underestimated meaning even
more people are living here than the
official number reflects and that would
mean government policies especially
around housing aren't based on real
numbers Mackenzie gray explains
tackling the housing crisis just got a
lot harder and not for the reason you'd
think the latest culprit a statistical
error I believe that we are under
accounting the number of non-permanent
residents in Canada by roughly 1 million
cibc's deputy chief Economist Benjamin
tall estimating official government
figures on immigration are wrong he
believed 750 000 non-permanent residents
mainly International students have
overstayed their visas and are still in
Canada and an additional 250 000 were
not properly counted in the most recent
census calculations tall briefed the
Prime Minister and his cabinet on last
week in Charlottetown this is something
that we have to fix because it has major
implications for demand for housing and
if we are under counting them we are
also under counting the amount of
Housing and therefore Mr locations are
located in resources implications also
for key data from the Canadian housing
and mortgage corporation which estimated
5.8 million new housing units must be
built by 2030 but that's based on
potentially inaccurate Census Data great
as the need is for housing we've
actually underestimated the need to
produce rental demand housing Minister
Sean Frazier floated the idea of a cap
on international student visas we've got
temporary immigration programs that were
never designed to see such explosive
growth in such a short period of time
one of many ideas tall believes
government should implement this is a
major crisis and it's getting worse and
worse we have to run faster to stay in
the same place because Supply is not
Rising a demand is rising very very
quickly CIBC estimates that the
potential undercount of non-permanent
residents means they'll need to be an
additional two years worth of building
at current rates Donna to soak up the
additional demand in the Canadian
housing market
okay Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks an
incident with a trailer load of beehives
in Burlington Ontario this morning had
beekeepers running to the rescue crates
containing about 5 million bees came
loose from the trailer spilling onto a
road and allowing many of the bees to
escape local beekeepers came to help
putting the crates back on the trailer
police urged motorists passing by to
keep their windows up they told
pedestrians to avoid the area it took a
couple of hours and a few crates are
being left behind so the bees that
escaped will return to them at some
point and the beekeepers will come and
collect them no word on how many people
were stung
a military coup in another African
nation coming up the dispute over
gamboa's election and the Jubilation in
the streets
Russian officials claim Ukraine launched
the biggest nighttime drone attack on
Russian soil since the beginning of the
war cell phone video shows the moment
drones reportedly hit an airport in
Western Russia near the border with
Estonia and Latvia early Wednesday at
least four Transport Aircraft were said
to be damaged drone attacks were also
reported in at least five other Russian
regions
really
coincide with moscow's largest missile
and drone attacks on Kiev in months at
least two people were killed after an
overnight bombardment that left several
others injured Ukrainian officials say
more than 20 missiles and drones were
destroyed by air defense systems in the
region
and a little later we'll have an inside
look at how those Russian airstrikes
have pushed learning underground in one
of Ukraine's biggest cities
the longtime leader of Gabon is under
house arrest tonight after Military
Officers claimed to have seized power in
the Central African nation Gabon on
Africa's West Coast has a population
about of about 2.3 million people the
coup happened just hours after the
president was declared the winner of a
controversial election which would have
extended his family's 55-year Reign Mike
Armstrong has the story
the military coup was announced
overnight and this was the reaction when
the capital woke up cheering crowds
celebrating in the streets of libreville
this is Independence this woman says the
Army has liberated our country
a military spokesman called the coup a
step for the people of the country on
the road to happiness announcing the
longtime president is now under house
arrest
Billy Bongo cast his ballot Saturday in
the presidential election according to
gabon's electoral commission he won with
just over 64 percent of the vote
the soldiers now say they are canceling
those results and dissolving the
institutions of the Republic right now
Bongo was allowed to release a statement
in English from house arrest he called
on supporters to speak out nothing is
happening I don't know what's what's
going on so I'm calling you to make the
noise
to make noise
now there was serious criticism of the
recent election the main opposition
candidate was given only eight days to
campaign and then said some polling
stations didn't have his name on ballots
there were no International observers or
International media and the government
cut off access to the internet it said
to cut down on false information
Bongo and his father before him have led
the country for 55 years and despite a
wealth of Natural Resources about a
third of the population lives below the
poverty line
if the public appears to support the
coup and let's say it's because many
were frustrated they were asking
themselves why should he be elected yet
again and in a process which doesn't
look terribly transparent sub-Saharan
Africa has had several military coups in
the last four years the most recent was
Niger just last month the reasons may be
different but seeing successful coups in
other countries was likely an influence
if not inspiration Mike Armstrong Global
News
[Music]
every year in a village near Valencia
Spain it's a tomato fight in case you
didn't couldn't tell and people travel
from all over the world for it hopefully
with goggles it's known as La Tomatina
it originated in 1945 it was banned in
the 1950s but survived and surged in
popularity nearly a hundred and ten
thousand kilos of overripe and low
quality Tomatoes were used or abused in
just one hour this year
I had medical concerns about Mitch
McConnell after a second episode in two
months
[Music]
in the U.S the Senate minority leader
Mitch McConnell froze again today while
he was taking questions from reporters
what are my thoughts about what running
for re-election in 2016.
that's true
did you hear the question Senator
running for reelection in 2026
all right I'm sorry you all we're gonna
need a minute
McConnell who is 81 years old was silent
for about 20 seconds he was guided Away
by staff he returned several minutes
later saying he was fine it's the second
time this has happened this summer The
Republican lawmaker froze during a press
conference on Capitol Hill in July and
Aid said today McConnell will consult a
doctor before his next event as a
prudent measure
a landmark moment for indigenous rights
in Australia that country is set to vote
on changing the Constitution to create a
so-called indigenous voice to Parliament
the referendum the country's first in 24
years will be held October 14th if
successful an indigenous Advisory Group
will be formed to advise government on
laws and issues that directly impact
indigenous Australians supporters say
embedding the indigenous body within the
Constitution will help Australia heal
after generations of racial Injustice
live and learn next the underground
classrooms aimed at keeping Ukrainian
students safe from Russia's War
returning to school is top of mind for
parents and students in lots of
countries right now and in Ukraine the
stress is unimaginable UNICEF says more
than 1300 schools have been destroyed in
the country since moscow's full-scale
Invasion only about a third of
school-aged children are able to attend
class in person one of Ukraine's biggest
cities is looking to change that by
taking classrooms underground Crystal
gemancing explains
Ukraine's underground Metro system has
been a lifesaver especially in harkiv
the eastern city lies on the border with
Russia and the bombardments have been
Relentless the bunker style stations
make for secure locations for learning
we will have desks and interactive board
Wi-Fi tutors and psychologists will be
here Victoria kruznitzova's head of the
Metro University project and gave a tour
of what will be 60 classrooms for 1 000
students sound proofing ventilation and
fire alarms are being added
I support that the children will study
in the subway says this mother she adds
she's glad they'll be able to socialize
in classes twice a week for three hours
UNICEF has been tracking the loss of
safe learning spaces for students and
asking how it's impacted them this is
senseless a reckless talk have left many
of Ukrainian children deeply distressed
and without a safe space to learn
four educational workers were killed in
the Sumi region last week as they were
preparing for the upcoming Academic Year
in harkiv region the governor says
Russian troops damaged 640 and destroyed
72 educational institutions
my children will attend online classes
though our school offered a bus to
transfer children to the subway
formal learning has been taking place in
Metro stations but as heart cave Works
to set up traditional classrooms the
idea of traveling back and forth to
attend school is seen by some parents as
an unnecessary risk
Crystal gemancing Global News London
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is Toronto CN Tower and the
rare super Blue Moon here's what that
means a super moon happens when the moon
is full during the closest point in its
orbit around Earth making it appear
bigger and brighter than a regular full
moon and this one's called a blue moon
not because it's blue but because it is
the second full moon of the month which
is extremely rare once in a blue moon
its visibility Peaks tonight there won't
be another Super Blue Moon until 2037.
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]